well we all know about the issues that
have existed for tyler malley here in
cincinnati we also know last time he
faced these nationals he did very very
well
strike three called 199
fastball down and away
not gonna do anything with that pitch
and angel hernandez behind the dish to
call third strike as reach base in 19 of
his last 25 played appearances and soto
swings sky's one of the air short left
field coming in in a hurry as delino de
shields he will get there and shallow
left to make the catch and tyler malley
has a one two three first inning we go
to the bottom of the first out of the
first inning and left-hander josh rogers
set to go to work 11th round pick of the
yankees in 2015 out of louisville makes
his fifth start for the nationals 2-0
record of 2.16 era
india well struck and kibum's right
there
a lunge toward the line josh rogers has
one out in the first hey ready to play
baseball on his toes nice play carter ki
boom
little half step and a dive saves not
just a hit but extra bases rogers kicks
delivers swinging a line drive right at
the shortstop escobar he makes the catch
and the side is retired
he's been aggressive they've been
swinging early hopefully he will be able
to pitch late into this game
tyler o'malley a career high
200 strikeouts here's carter kibum back
in the lineup today trying to get things
going on the back half of this road trip
one for 11 on the roadie thus far
that ball's driven to left
back off the wall
riley adams will turn for third kibum in
the second
and that's the
loudest
carter kibum has
squared a ball up in the last couple
weeks that was well struck a little
modified leg kick here look at not as
high just a tiny little leg kick can go
and maybe that kept the head a little
bit more still he gets something up and
drills it to left there goes the no
hitter first knock of the day for the
gnats a double a booming double off the
wall for carter kibum thomas was called
out on strikes and his first at bat
swing and a miss high festival not
catching up to that one i'm not sure why
thomas was shaking his head he's the one
that was swinging the bat but he went
after a pitch that was definitely out of
the strike zone
that could be trouble indeed out extends
the club and makes the catch so second
and third with no outs and tyler malley
comes smelling like a rose he gets three
in a row to get out of it we're
scoreless bottom of three coming up to
begin the second soto mali battle
pops him up again
longer run for suarez and mali
suarez
one down then again it means bases empty
for josh bell who led off the second and
grounded out
strike three cold five k's for mellie
it's a little sunday paint work with the
fastball that's what you what we expect
from tyler fastball looking strikeouts
carter
smoked a double his last time
drives that one in an o2 count to the
opposite field two great swings from
carter kibum today he's two for two
fastball away hit it away you can see
how still his head is there
with second with two out and lane thomas
the batter
ground ball right side india boots it
hernandez or rather kibum coming around
he'll score
an adventure for jonathan india at
second base today and he cost the reds a
run here in the fifth the nationals have
the lead i sat on it you see that you
see that last hop there it's starting to
dry out he sat on it number one jonathan
india leads off he's lined to third fly
to center rogers kicks and delivers the
pitch to india smoke to left field that
ball is scorched and over the head of
the leaping left fielder hernandez and
short hops the wall and india is on his
way into second base with a double i
don't care how i do it i made that error
when i get up there i'm getting this
thing back somehow someway i'm getting
on base and india does just that now a
chance for the reds with abandoned
scoring position tyler stevenson
in the air to pretty deep right soto
back and that's gone
the 10th home run for tyler stevenson
and the reds lead it two to one don't
give yourself up trying to get him over
hit the ball at the ballpark getting him
over
castaianos
crushes it high in the air deep left
center
it just felt like once he got that 30th
home run monkey off his back that it
loosened up his game
he plays with such a
i don't know it's a it's a looseness and
some swagger and some thumb he hit his
30th on friday
and he's now got his first run of three
straight games with a homer on now tyler
stevenson couple of hits today he is
heating up two run homers last time up
that's a fair ball in trouble
friedle flies through second hernandez
just now digs the ball step side to
third good throw in standing double for
stevenson
he is a triple shy of the cycle
bases loaded two outs
farmer in the air deep left field kyle
farmer
the word you hear during that bat
against harper is stay back stay back
stay back and let the ball travel that's
all about discipline farm dog got a ball
up in the zone he stayed back and was
rewarded he had 42 career rbis nine home
runs entering this year that's his 16th
homer and he's got 63 ribbies as the
everyday show
the rookie makes his major league debut
of the young man who dominated in the
miners dowry mourinho
that's a fair ball suarez on the charge
bare hand is only playing first bit of a
tall throw cabrera comes down to the bag
that's a great play by geno that ball
has all kind of spin on it comes in on
the move to bare hand this ball
swing and a miss dowry moreno welcome to
the show his first big league strikeout
and his first inning is the scoreless
one here garrett comes on
well amir has been pretty good last time
out perfect inning
first pitch to third suarez feeds into
one relay in time double play
watch how he does not drop his hands
this time catch the ball about chest
level see how he just throws from the
chest level jose barrero barrero taps
each side of the plate waves the bat
back and forth
fair ball
the shields through second pereiro rips
around first william is on for the
shields
he sprints home
rbi doubled by jose barrero 8-1
stevenson high in the air to center
thomas bearley bunches runners tag at
second and third
guerrero scores aquino avoids the tag in
third base sec fly rbi
and i'm glad barrero hustled because
this was a close play at third base
up and coming on for the second
consecutive day
stroke to center pereiro coming on
headlong dive makes the play
brilliant catch by jose
a little slight delay but plenty of foot
speed
[Applause]
oh my goodness
curveball goes about 50 feet everybody
moves up garcia scores and the nationals
have their second run of the game still
fighting we've seen this from this ball
club all year the most non-competitive
pitch i've seen in a long time 2-2
the reds take the game and the series
they route the nationals
in this finale
you